what's up reject nation we are going to
watch today from new rock stars the
what-if finale easter eggs and breakdown
of course as usual very much looking
forward to this i want to thank you for
clicking on this video i want to thank
new rock stars for encouraging our
reactions to their hard work always
bring an appreciation every single
episode pretty much anything that we
cover from them but a good journey but
can't end season one without checking
out this one first you know how we do if
you end up enjoying our video hit that
like button or the dislike doesn't
matter just a vote
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 9 what if the watcher
broke his oath a season finale that
assembles the guardians of the
multiverse to avenge vegas
as always this episode was filled with
interesting details and connections to
the live action mcu with major
implications for the multiverse going
forward so i'm going to break it all
down frame by frame for everything that
you might have missed say major
implications for the multiverse going
forward we thought that would be what
loki is doing and we haven't seen any of
that really have an affect just yet
we've got in shanghai we've got an even
this which doesn't acknowledge the
events up there
yeah i hope the events of here have
major implications for the future of the
marvel cinematic universe we open with
captain carter after her jump to the
present era in episode 1 following in
the footsteps of steve rogers and the
lumerian star mission from the opening
of captain america winter soldier peggy
now wears the blue and white stealth
suit that steve wore but with a union
jack pattern across the chest instead
and natasha has a shorter haircut that
she had in that film their target is
once again bat rock except before it was
rumlow briefing everyone how many
pirates
25
top mercs led by this guy
george
peggy leads this briefing how many
pirates 20 or so chalmers led by this
one culture ruining everything we later
learned that nick
actually hired batroc to hijack the
lumerian star because he was suspicious
of shields true intentions for project
insight and he secretly ordered natasha
to steal data from those computers you
know i'm getting a little tired of being
a furious janitor relax it's not that
complicated so now peggy leading the
briefing suggests that this is her
mission not fury's operation which might
be why the cargo is different from
project insight related stuff as we
learned the post-credits scene her steve
rogers old hydra stomper armor with
someone inside we could see biometrics
over on the left so that someone is
alive but assuming shield was still
being corrupted by hydra at this point
this hydro stopper could have been part
of hydra's winter soldier program since
if you think about it steve did kind of
take bucky's place back in episode one
and it would be one way of explaining
how steve survived this long setting up
poor peggy in this awkward conflict now
with steve rogers in a kind of iron lung
brainwashed by hydra sound theory but
what i really love that you pointed out
was the vitals showing that there is
someone alive in there presumably steve
rogers 99.99 likely steve rogers because
i did see some debate going around of
are we sure steve rogers is actually
alive what if they're just a corpse
inside of there so that right there is
evidence that yes indeed he is alive so
good work once again vos check now we
hear the variant capture carter theme
from episode one gentlemen watch our six
strike team you heard the captain gear
up this episode is actually great with
musical light motifs including a piano
rendition of steve's theme and there's
someone inside
the guardians theme
stay here
leave this fight to us killmonger's
theme
doctor strange's theme
and the avengers theme
add the fred's theme song just as
natasha tried to hook up steve with
kristen from statistics natasha does the
same with peggy you know bernard in
accounting was asking about you nothing
good has ever followed the phrase
bernard in accounting or bernard
accountants make great partners peggy
nothing good has ever happened
especially bernard is adam bernard
brashear blue marble because if so you
got to get on that but natasha says
widow yeah peggy is still sore over
never getting that dance with steve
rogers which she brings up again when
she tells batroc she's a pretty good
dancer and when peggy catches her shield
it kicks off a little puff of vapor
slicing through the night air and in
this thick sea layer with eyes gleaming
to match the bright full moon is the
watcher captain carter the soldier lost
in time you have been chosen so yes the
watcher is recruiting the dream team to
save the multiverse that comes from what
if number 39 what if the watcher saved
the universe in which she forms a team
consisting of thor an android iron man
doctor doom from the fantastic five and
vampire wolverine
yeah oh that just made me realize that
by the time what if season two comes
around they have the mutants but they
haven't brought them forth yet in the
marvel cinematic universe by the time
one of season two comes around they
might actually be able to toy around
with doctor doom fantastic for the
mutants my goodness there's so much
awaiting us an alternate version of
white blade we got so much coming our
way
we need a white blade i've been saying
it for years now and from this we
kaleidoscope wipe over to the dairy
queen in missouri from episode 2 as well
as the guardians volume 2 film and here
we see ego linking with peter quill to
form the expansion from that film but
t'challa's ship then mandela actually
leads the other ravagers ship in the
strike and ego says relax son it'll all
be over in a thousand years or so just a
reminder of ego's plan in that film to
use quill as a thousand-year battery i
wanted to do this together
that i suppose you'll have to learn by
spending the next thousand years as a
battery and then on to
they're so cool of course the weapons
forgery from infinity war if you want to
revisit guardians
thanos's double-bladed sword and wears
the armor that she wore in 2014 in end
game as well as each last episode
in the hulkbuster armor with sakara
decor the three of them melty in the
infinity gauntlet i really wanted it to
do a t2 thumbs up
but apparently this is the oh that would
have been so
delayed to season two which would have
shown gamora killing thanos on sakaar
they say it was delayed because of kovid
i call [ __ ] producing animation
remotely it's not like trying to do live
action remotely they totally could have
got it done there was some plot reason
that they delayed it i'm telling you i
think this plot would have involved tony
stark in age of ultron hulkbuster armor
taking hulk's place on the quinjet to
sakaar and maybe thanos sacrificing
nebula on vermeer instead of gamora's
that peter quill didn't stupidly break
his trance and they could have stopped
thanos earlier another possibility is
that stark could have gotten stuck on
the other side of that wormhole in the
first avengers film when he nuked
thanos's forces and then maybe got
stranded on sakaar
hulkbuster armor from scratch in a dump
with a pile
first off it would be so cool if any of
those plot lines that you just pitched
were the ones that come true by the time
we see it in season two but i've heard
about that with animation it's like
we've seen that with anime so much at
the time too a lot of the times the dubs
are not completed because of what's
happened with kovet yeah so it's not
exactly unheard of i don't exactly know
why that's the case but it would make
sense that they would have the episode
in season one considering this is the
team up of all the characters coming
together in the finale so i don't see
what other alternate reason there would
be for not featuring it in season one
when they've said we pushed it to season
two specifically because i'm like i feel
like the excitement of it is kind of
undercut knowing the outcome yeah i feel
like yeah it's weird i actually kind of
buy the coven thing because unless they
have some grand plan as to why this
story needs to move it does feel weird
to put it out of sync with this ultimate
team up that it would have been nice to
have some context for gamora's
involvement yeah yeah yeah now notice
each still has his hands whereas in the
main mcu continuity thanos cut off his
hands
yeah good catch good catch man stumps an
uru so something changed maybe they used
a reality stone to bring his hands back
before pulverizing the stones with the
infinity crusher or the animators didn't
give a [ __ ] now tony armor had some
upgrades including some huge discs on
the shoulders maybe these are the stuff
that's why the episode got pushed back
signs that we used to subdue hulk in the
2008 film and were actually later added
to his drones and spider-man far from
home also there are three claws on each
fist
did tony run into wolverine is that why
this episode was delayed in season two
oh my god oh my oh oh crap oh wait wait
a minute okay theory
maybe here's maybe you're right
because yeah if there's a mutative
there's a wolverine appearance then yes
i get why they would absolutely want to
see they do have the gladiator matches
yeah yeah yeah so maybe faced off with
wolverine then was like hey that's a
great idea i'm going to scrap some claws
onto my hulk bust which would then make
watching this episode exciting and
worthwhile even though we know the end
result it would make it worthwhile when
you're looking at the promos like oh my
god a wolverine versus iron man yeah and
plus i mean in the anthology world is
still being thrilling to see gamora take
out thanos anyway yeah that's true but
this would have been the one episode
this season to spare tony stark's life
and here he says how do we put a suit of
armor around the world
around the galaxy you can't tell me
there's not another big bad lurking in
the shadows monster under the bed always
what that suit of armor it's like it's
only metaphor now gamora sees this big
bad as the watcher reflected in tony's
sikarian plating but i think this line
was added to redirect this delayed
episode as one setting up the season one
finale to instead one connected to
season two and whatever season two's new
multiversal big bad will be now while
kang seems like a good bet i think the
other watchers with whom who wants who
made his oath and now broke that oath
coming to seek accountability could also
be the possible new big bad shuri and
pepper lead the dormilage against
killmonger from episode six pepper
wielding that gun that looks like the
one based on the asgardian destroyer
armor that coulson wielded in the first
avengers film and shuri wielded her by
bringing in cockpits from black panther
weaponizing those alongside a refusal to
get vaccinated
[Laughter]
yeah the watchers eyes narrow on killer
showing the watcher probably knows he
cannot trust killmonger and it's
killmonger's traitor's behavior that is
why the watcher probably needs him on
his team now in vegas thor wrestles
ultron centuries following ultron's
arrival episode seven nobody messes with
vegas
yeah i like how the frame initially pans
over to just show part of the watcher in
the sky that's supposed to be clear
shots for all the other recruits just
shows how party thor is super distracted
so the watcher reaches down to grab him
like a toy
[Music]
yeah he's still screaming all the way to
his new location just as he does yeah
but more importantly he continues to
clutch that severed ultron sentry head
which killmonger later uses so you could
argue catching thor off guard just like
this was also part of the watcher's
master plan probably that head and
killmonger's hand i mean i think it all
is part of the plan doesn't dr strange
say in the ending moments that like
everything went exactly according to how
you foresaw that it would go yeah i mean
he does try to get his attention but i
feel like yeah the watcher knows all and
experiences everything at all moments so
it probably is part of his plan
ultimately i mean it's a little
mathematical about it and i mean you
know you have to kind of count on a lot
of happenstance what's happenstance to a
watcher well it seems like this incident
took him by surprise everything that
happened with ultron and then he had to
go against how he saw the timelines
playing out and then assemble this team
is there some theoretical aspect to the
watcher where he can like kind of play
with some chess pieces foresee how this
would go to if he were to implement and
move stuff around or is he just strictly
watching or can he actually pull strings
because it sounded like he could pull
strings in this episode it would seem as
though maybe he can
see a couple steps ahead of every
decision or something like that they are
transported to the same pub that peggy
and steve got a drink in in episode one
thor orders a beer from doctor strange
just like he gets one from him in
ragnarok and then he chugs and smashes
it just as he does pretty much every
drink in his hand
the watcher explains at first i scoured
eternity for one true hero then i saw
the bigger picture
this mission requires a team the perfect
combination of skills and experience
that alone will triumph so the watcher
needs more than just one or even a
thousand cosmically powerful warriors
really he needs a specific ragtag group
of underdogs that ultron would
underestimate but also one of whom would
betray the rest and allow the stones to
be sequestered so this isn't a true
dream team it's really a band of misfits
like the guardians of the galaxy which
is why he calls them you are
the guardians of the multiverse so when
thor tries to leave outside the bar is
the swirling storm the pub exterior made
up of doctor strange's eldritch magic
and a clockwork grid i love that
production design here it kind of looks
like strange hid them in a dimension
between realities like the surreal zones
that he zipped through in the doctor
strange film same imagery used in the no
way home trailer the golden color
palette does match the portal through
which wanda maximoff saw her future
scarlet which itself i just think this
may be the same kind of setting that
multiverse of madness takes place in
familiar fragments of broken realities
reconstructed amidst a chaotic hellstorm
doctor strange
each controlling an essential aspect of
our existence yes it's the same lecture
that wong explains to stark in infinity
war big banks and six elemental crystals
these infinity stones each control an
essential aspect of existence as they
discuss the mission killmonger is almost
always staring at the ultron sentry head
now this head is probably made of
vibranium as all the final form ultrons
were which is the same as killmonger's
suit which that hum that we heard
earlier indicated
what do you want with us all good
questions they order chinese takeout
just like the avengers do when
brainstorming the time heist and end
game and gamora presents the infinity
crusher a device of knit valerian design
with gears like a rock grinder the
infinity crusher designed to
disintegrate each stone into nothing now
infinity stones according to in-game
directors cannot be fully destroyed
since infinity stones are needed to
maintain a universe's proper flow of
time but they can be atomized and
prevented from actual use that's likely
what this crusher does thor says yes
there's a few people in the room that
don't understand
not me i get it but for them maybe
repeat it
you're ready yeah the watcher decides
they're ready in spite of thor's dumb
statement here this shows that he is
actually counting on thor lee roy
jenkins into this mission
thanos into exactly exactly
protection spells for each of them and i
like how each has a different pattern
like there's a five-pointed star a
six-pointed one some sons i assume each
using mysticism from a different
tradition and actually later we see the
five-pointed stars for captain carter as
if her protection is linked with steve
rogers both t'challa and killmonger have
the sun pattern maybe not in their
african roots oh how neat squares in a
kind of norse runic pattern and gamora
gets the interlaid triangles with nodes
around the circumference evoking an
alien sicarium in design
so this is this is what i'm talking
about this already right here only
halfway through this breakdown and
already i'm like well this episode's
better than i realized it was
so much attention to detail so many
character moments yeah i just wish what
if had like 10 to 15 extra more minutes
in order to let some of their episodes
breathe a little bit better bring out
some more emotional moments out of
things to really have it be felt because
yeah like even looking at the
foreshadowing of eric killmonger looking
at the vibranium helmet that obviously
is him realizing that there's more
capability of weaponizing the vibranium
that he even realized and it's something
that kind of flew over my head in the
immediate moment of it because it was
going by so quick but yeah when you slow
it down here i'm like wow that is that
is true that is the moment he's going
wow look at the capabilities of what we
can do even right here to um the
protection spells and the attention to
detail on it because all those symbols
are like whoop nope didn't notice any of
that season two i want an episode with
no dialogue just so that it's all visual
animation appreciation yeah and then the
spells coat them like armor giving thor
a winged crown killmonger and gamora
shoulder armor and t'challa in a crown
and an extra layer on his necklace as he
is the rightful king of wakanda and
peggy has some chunky medieval looking
armor for her english roots strange's
squid demon from episode 4 emerges from
his hand peggy who later stares down
this beast in the final battle
recognizes this anatomy as some that she
fought in episode one that's what i'm
talking about
that's what i'm talking about
can i ask what happened
same thing that happened to you strange
gives a toast a wise sorcerer once told
me that to face death is part of the
plan to face death is to conquer one's
greatest fear of the unknown of
nothingless space yeah it sounds like
he's trying to quote the ancient one's
death speech
death is what gives life meaning to know
your days are numbered your time is
short
ultron finds them first as a giant face
in the sky as the watcher usually does
but way bigger and he arrives through an
interdimensional portal with that
crystalline texture showing his mastery
now over the multiverse as on par with
watcher now ultron uses a fun
combination of the soul reality and
power stones but not the space stone to
crumble the mountain that they're
standing on i suppose the soul stone in
this case to isolate which souls under
which the ground to warp the reality of
and the power stone to give it all in
whom exactly is a weird way to judge the
functionality of we really just saw it
when thanos used to isolate which
strange was the real one in the wizard
dual infinity war actually strange uses
that same images of icon spell to
duplicate mjolnir and swarm them around
ultron strange magics of peggy's shield
to create a mjolnir plus shield shock
wave and then she hitches a ride back
with one of the mjolnirs the way
spider-man did in end game t'challa
grabs ultron and gets thrown off you can
actually see the moment that he snatches
the soul stone and it's pretty
impressive he does it with the hand that
he's holding the blaster with yeah
whoa
cool
we actually saw him absorb two of these
in episode four which i thought was
redundant animation at the time but nope
three dragon heads are better than one
strange opens a portal from the zombie
universe the first ones to fall on
ultron are zombie cap zombie falcon and
zombie hawkeye zombie cap was split down
the middle of his body i guess just
think about it thousands more out pile
up but worst among them is zombie wanda
maximoff who should have the power to
break an infinity stone like she did the
mindstone of vision's head in infinity
war but she softens briefly maybe
because she recognizes this red
synthazoid face as that of her love
vision but i'll try and use this
residency to blow up the freaking planet
oh yeah it makes sense now yeah i didn't
even really criticize it
i was just like she's a zombie she don't
really know what she's doing
yeah that romero thing of like the
echoes of her past life is still in
there what was that zombie calling day
of the dead oh dang it's not boomer it's
it's he's got a name named ted franklin
is it ed
we're such a good movie fan
i know it and i can't write to mine i
guess what i'm saying the breakdowns
really helped me appreciate this show
that much more is because it's animated
and because they're so short that they
do feel like a comic book in the sense
of how you could sort of feel the
thought bubbles of what these characters
are having like with wanda maxim off in
that moment but without hearing it you
know but the thought bubbles are
happening you're just not hearing the
language that's going on in their heads
yeah you get the motion to fill in the
blank but yeah i get exactly because
they do really read that way and the
observant john and greg never even think
twice about what they might be thinking
that we just go lack of writing
lazy writers
rushed episodes rush the animation lazy
writing and as they exit through the
portal thor does a backwards jump just
like peter quill did in infinity war and
they returned to ultron's home reality
on post-apocalyptic earth to crush the
stone from the signs this actually looks
like tokyo peggy needs to prove to
natasha that she knows her your father
is ivan your dars alexi and you're the
one woman i trust to have my six she
uses red skull's genealogy from end game
data of ivan but it's interesting that
peggy wouldn't know that because natasha
did not know it but then yes of course
her da being alexi and not to alexis
shostakov her fake dad of kgb from black
widow i think one thing that this
episode in particular did really well
especially at the offside of it and this
is something we didn't touch on you
could really feel the history and
kinship that has formed between peggy
and natasha you know it's one one of the
fun things about swapping out captain
america with captain carter yes captain
america has a very specific type of
friendship with natasha this one feels
like they really are best friends yeah
and i think that's something that this
episode even in the small little doses
you got it did capture really well
so woke ultron flips out why won't we
die
that's a reference to toad from x-men
wait
what yeah good question well it's
because strange still has the power of
the time stone as we see later in this
battle meaning that he could rewind
ultron's explosion the way thanos
rewinded wanda blowing up the mind stone
and then consumed the boom boom the way
he did all of those demons peggy says
give him all you've got don't give him a
chance to think which also tells us a
bit about their strategy right it's not
about beating ultron head to head it's
about overwhelming him so that he cannot
process his next move and like the
avengers dog piling on thanos on titan
we get this awesome long take of each of
them landing their blows on ultra
followed by another long take but just
on the close-up of the cell stone for 11
seconds as people fight over it i love
using the soul stone as the synecdoche
for all of their souls the watcher
this is the stone that we've seen the
least of the mcu representing the whole
of it in this battle ultron uses the
time stone to suspend them all in slow
motion while he reclaims the soul stone
but strange uses his own time stone to
neutralize this spell this is the first
time we have seen one infinity stone use
against a variant universe infinity
stone so by this logic duplicate stones
do retain their power even when they
share a universe but so far i guess when
one is used against the other it just
cancels each other out ultron grows big
and strange allows those demons inside
them to take over which the artists show
with this amazing effect probably my
favorite shot of the episode the energy
splitting the frame in a different
states of being for strange one layer
showing strange the layer underneath
showing his demonic form it's just a
really tactile expression of strange
painfully ripping himself apart to do
this they pin ultron and use the
infinity crusher but uh
every universe is different each one
just a fraction unique
the crusher was designed to destroy the
stones on my world not his yes of course
the framing matches the avengers circle
up shot in the first avengers film and
here this episode establishes yet
another bit of infinity stone rulemaking
i feel like they really are building up
doctor strange to be the head of the mcu
the way how iron man was essentially the
main face of the mcu and now that he's
gone i really think they have been
slowly catapulted and i think that's one
thing this show in particular has done
remarkably well is that the the biggest
character takeaway i think has been even
though it's a different version of
doctor strange a lot of the attention
and focus goes to dr strange even right
down to ultron being like if i take you
out this team sucks yeah yeah this
team's done for you know and the
earliest elements of serialized
storytelling that come into this season
are with doctor strange and the watcher
as they sort of yeah crest into the
final end game of the season while
duplicate stones can both function in a
shared universe they can only be
destroyed by something from their same
home universe okay natasha uses the
arrow with zola's ai from episode 8.
if you think about it she only had
because ultron in this moment is
focusing mostly on strange at least some
blind spots and i think this is again
part of the watchers plan to delay
natasha's ace in her hole to the last
minute like this peggy uses the arrow to
take out one of voltron's eyes and in
this moment you can see on the infinity
stones are now glowing somewhat duller
after this point because in ultron's
mind his ultron consciousness is
battling with the zola ai and zola uses
the same kind of snakey neuron bolt
attacks that ultron used to kill jarvis
and i love how those eight strands match
the eight tentacles of the hydra sigil
ultron is dead but killmonger still has
that head with ultron's consciousness
left glowing in it and his vibranium
link allows him control of the reality
stone to assemble his own killmonger
infinity armor
[Music]
aha that was the fool of flute which
composer ludwig joranson used as
killmonger's unique sound in black
panther peter and the wolf style and
that riff sounded like a real victorious
but also belligerent blow expressing
killmonger being drunk on power here the
killmonger infinity is challenged i am
afraid that armor belongs to me
finally zola's android form from the
comics with his face in the tummy a
design teased as an easter egg in the
first cap film coming to life and they
tug of war over the stones with this
little ripped in space kind of evoking
their big bang origin i like that touch
i actually thought of uh i just didn't
want to piss off the audience entirely
at the time but i thought of when rey
and kylo
have that shot in the last jedi
when they're or when they're dealing
with one of the
well
[Laughter]
yeah
i'm pissed off already but strange
realizes we were never meant to win
we were here to separate the stones from
the body and so he creates a pocket
dimension around them trapping them both
you foresaw every moment from the failed
infinity crusher to kill monger's
betrayal he lives in a russian dog
sacrifice yes one wonders how far back
the watchers plan went was it to his
team up with doctor strange or even
before that and with this episode titled
what if the watcher broke his oath we
never really see the consequences of
that broken oath i do plan to explore
the watcher's full plan and his next
steps in a video coming soon they all
return to their home realities but peggy
carter wants to go back to the 40s
haven't i earned my happy ending for
reasons i assume we will see in season
two since captain carter is confirmed as
a vocal character for this whole series
and will likely be linked with the
rediscovery of steve in the hydrostomper
armor in the post-credits scene
meanwhile black widow he allows to join
the one episode not referenced thus far
in the valley episode three which ended
with nick fury teaming up steve rogers
with carol danvers to fight loki's
takeover of earth this shield
helicarrier is numbered 64 the same
number from the first avengers film and
this could provide one way natasha
romanov could ever return in live action
especially now that scarlett johansson
has wonderfully settled her legal
troubles with disney thanks to millions
of dollars in a payout and we're back
with the watchers saying every story is
my home
and i will protect it to the end
just like he said to natasha your
stories
they
are everything to me i love this because
yes while we have seen the watcher as a
kind of creepy voyeuristic figure his
sudden vulnerability here gives us
permission to have emotional attachments
to the stories that we watch yeah it's
okay to see pieces of ourselves and the
wins and losses of our heroes because
why are any of us here if not to stir
something inside of each other and with
that i want to thank you all so much for
playing watcher to this whole season of
coverage of marvel's what if these
breakdowns and our inside marvel after
shows it's just been a delight unpacking
it all together trying to keep up with
its elusive infinity stone logic and if
you want to support us the best way to
do it is by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks again for watching
fight
and i'll say that with their merch i
have a lot of shirts i have a lot of
t-shirts hands down their shirts are
honestly
incredibly comfortable
that's a rare there's a reason you see
me alternate between i have a lot but i
alternate between a few because i really
care about like yeah i don't like the
way it feels on my skin their shirts are
extremely comfortable so that's why i
look forward to buying whatever they got
to offer anyway guys thank you new
rockstars for putting this together
another fantastic job you did you did it
subscribed if you haven't done so
already hit that like button last but
not least
michael buble michael thank you so much
for being part of our patreon page not
only does michael b have a great
reaction channel does he not only cover
more shows than us he also has covered
all of what if he covered squid game and
he also is probably got a reaction up to
this specific marvel what if breakdown
from new rockstars as well if you enjoy
our video you made it this far do
yourself a favor subscribe to omni media
because i'm telling you he's better than
john
yeah he is
[Music]